nel solo 2009 e soltanto negli stati
uniti 140 istituti di credito hanno
dichiarato bancarotta
nello stesso anno dopo aver studiato
economia finanza e gestione dopo averli
studiati in italia svizzera e stati
uniti
mi sono laureato ero il prodotto di quel
sistema e dello stato formato per
pensare e agire come il sistema ebbe
visti i risultati
decisi di rinnegare e di fare
esattamente il contrario ha deciso di
tornare in italia e di aprire la mia di
impresa e il giorno che decisi che tipo
di struttura dare la mia impresa eravamo
in trento erano al tavolo oltre a me
c'erano i miei due attuali soci 1 un
ingegnere con 15 anni di conoscenza del
settore del legno e l'altro invece un
manager con 20 anni di conoscenza del
mercati esteri
avevamo background differenti ma un
piglio imprenditoriale eccezionalmente
simile avevamo il desiderio di fare
qualcosa di radicalmente diverso la così
opposto quello che c'era sul mercato da
poter funzionare più che innovare
facendo un balzo in avanti volevamo
innovare scartando di lato
prendiamo quindi un foglio bianco grande
e tracciamo una linea nel mezzo
da una parte scrivevamo quello che c'era
sul mercato quello che stava succedendo
dall'altra parte esattamente il
contrario e noi avremmo fatto il
contrario 2009 quelli che tipo di nuove
imprese c'erano che tipo di certi
prodotti c'erano sul mercato ben
tendenzialmente up social media facebook
oppure consulenza riga allora noi
avremmo fatto un prodotto avremmo fatto
manifattura bene per fare manifattura
serve una visione di imprese una visione
di prodotto ed è curioso quando uno
parla di visione che strizza sempre un
po gli occhi e quindi noi alla ricerca
di una visione chiara
cerchiamo la cosa più immediatamente
pertinente a visione visione occhi
occhiali faremo gli occhiali
sembrava una boutade il real
il mercato dell'occhialeria è molto
interessante si può sedurre il cliente
finale parlando di confort parlando di
design parlando di qualità
il dal punto di vista e di distribuzione
abbastanza eterogeneo quindi si può
dialogare con ottici indipendenti si può
dialogare con gruppi di acquisto e
quindi sembrava un mercato abbastanza
politico da permettere di sedurre
attaccare il cliente da diverse da
diverse angolazioni gli occhiali sono
tendenzialmente di accettato o metallo
riga noi li faremo il legno il legno
materiale nobile e caldo elegante e
molto contemporaneo e soprattutto il mio
socio sapeva sapeva tutto del legno
quindi occhiali di legno occhiali di
legno ossia e dove si fanno gli occhiali
oggi ma tendenzialmente dove costa di
meno quindi in cina o in one in riga
noi invece li faremo in italia con alta
qualità ma come in italia tutti fanno
sourcing vano cercare dei fornitori
specializzati riga
noi invece non solo cercheremo di
fornitori specializzati altrove ma
faremo la nostra manifattura di occhiali
nella quale avremo la proprietà il
controllo da come la tua manifattura
tutti vanno ricerca di economie di scala
per mantenere il prezzo basso riga e
allora noi manterremo il prezzo alto i
volumi sono attivati dal venduto e dal
pagato ma come volumi sono attivate la
visura pagata gli altri fanno il
magazzino per essere pronti a inondare
il mercato quando chiede qualcosa riga
noi daremo al mercato esattamente quello
che chiede in poche settimane ma come
esattamente quello che chiede gli
occhiali sono tendenzialmente l'ottanta
per cento
nerio color tartaruga è in realtà sono
tutti uguali riga e allora per la nostra
manifattura di occhiali in legno le tre
parole chiave saranno design colore e
personalizzazione ed ecco come è nata la
mia azienda
ad oggi la mia la nostra azienda è la
ragione per la quale 20 dipendenti la
val brembana una sessantina di venditori
in giro per il mondo e qualche
consulente si alzano
chi ne vanno a lavorare è la ragione per
la quale almeno un migliaio dei migliori
ottici del mondo vanno al lavoro con un
pizzico di orgoglio in più per quello
che fanno e dalla ragione per la quale
un piccolo grande esercito di
consumatori ha deciso di avere il
proprio nome scritto sull'occhiale non
quello di qualche di un altro
e nonostante partimmo da un approccio
provocatorio da bastian contrario l'idea
che avevamo in testa o meglio sul foglio
sottendeva un paradigma che era in grado
di reggersi se cinque condizioni cardine
potevano rispettarsi e noi aderimmo in
modo tenace aderiamo in modo e tenacia
quelle cinque condizioni la prima è che
per fare manifatture in italia bisogna
fare un prodotto ad alto valore aggiunto
che quindi può essere venduto a un
prezzo alto ma il prezzo deve essere
giustificato dalla qualità
nel nostro caso la qualità è
giustificata da tre elementi la ricerca
e sviluppo
i macchinari e le persone la ricerca e
sviluppo occupò due anni dal 2009 al
2011 e fu interamente finanziata da
capitale privato i macchinari di
sviluppano ad hoc qui sul territorio e
le persone mettemo facilmente assieme un
gruppo di persone che erano state
lasciate a casa a causa della crisi
erano persone che lavoravano nel settore
del legno quindi avevano lavorato per
molti anni magari prodotti poveri una
gamba del tavolo una testata del letto e
dovete sapere che per fare un occhiale
in legno come il nostro è necessario
avere molta professionalità molta
manualità e una cura del dettaglio
maniacale
fu una vera epifania scoprire che quando
andavamo a fare formazione ai nostri
ragazzi
loro non solo avevano l'innata capacità
di fare quel prodotto ma guardandoli
negli occhi sembravano voler dire ne
abbiamo la capacità anzi perché mai
nessuno ci ha chiesto qua di fare un
prodotto a così alto valore aggiunto
la seconda condizione del nostro
paradigma dopo qualità e la velocità di
esecuzione fare un prodotto portarlo sul
mercato venderlo raccogliere i feedback
e ripetere la velocità di esecuzione è
l'unica arma che una piccola media
impresa e una piccola media start up a
per tutelarsi quando i competitor
copiano soprattutto in un paese come
l'italia dove
tutelarsi dal punto di vista del know
how costa molti soldi e contempla tempi
molto molto lunghi
quando presentammo il nostro occhiale di
legno nel 2011 c'erano circa tre
produttori di altri occhiali di legno ad
oggi ce ne sono circa dai 50 e 60
ma quando loro presentarono l'occhiale
di legno lo presentiamo l'occhiale di
legno colore con molta personalità
quando cercarono di copiarci il design e
il colore presentammo l'occhiale di
legno vecchio di 48.000 anni quando
cercano di copiare i materiali nobili a
quel punto noi avevamo già una catena
distributiva strutturata e facendo leva
sulla nostra manifattura davamo un
servizio di unicità direttamente al
nostro cliente ad oggi abbiamo un piano
di sviluppo prodotti a 30 mesi che
risponde a furti di proprietà
intellettuale più o meno velata la terza
condizione dopo alta qualità e velocità
e non avere il magazzino il magazzino è
uno spreco di risorse non avere
magazzino significa salvare l'ambiente
la nostra coscienza ambientale è il
migliore consulente o professore di
economia del quale possiamo dotare la
nostra azienda essere eco friendly non
significa avere dei certificati sul
proprio prodotto certificate sul proprio
processo ma significa sviluppare una
forma mentis che tende a eliminare
magazzino a ridurre detta rilevazione
congenito del materiale a ottimizzare la
logistica e questo fa bene tanto
all'ambiente quanto più al budget
consuntivo di spesa soprattutto in un
paese come l'italia dove la prima causa
di fallimento per piccole e medie
imprese e la mancanza di liquidità nel
breve termine
quindi avere magazzino ovvero denaro
seduto in azienda inutilizzabile e la
peggiore minaccia che possiamo portare
in azienda
il quarto punto dopo qualità velocità e
zero magazzino è avere il controllo e la
consistenza sui quattro elementi del
piano marketing
il piano marketing sono quegli elementi
che utilizziamo per dialogare con il
mercato sono il prodotto servizio che
vendiamo
dove lo vendiamo a quanto lo vendiamo e
come lo raccontiamo faber est suae
quisque fortunae ciascuno è artefice
della propria sorte
e per essere artefici della propria
sorte quando si fa impresa bisogna avere
il controllo tanto a monte sulla ricerca
e sviluppo sulla manifattura su acquisti
quanto a valle avere la possibilità di
avere le leve che dialogano col mercato
in termini di distribuzione e in termini
di comunicazione e da controllo ha
consistenza in matematica
si dice che una teoria è consistente
quando è impossibile dimostrare al suo
interno una contraddizione applicato a
una piccola impresa questo significa che
un prodotto bello deve essere venduto in
un posto bello raccontato in un modo
bello è presentato al pubblico in un
plauso un prezzo che sia coerentemente
consistentemente bello alto l'essenziale
è invisibile agli occhi diceva il
piccolo principe un bel prodotto da solo
non arriva sul mercato senza laurea di
magia data da la comunicazione dalla
distribuzione
esistono due qualità ha due
caratteristiche dalla qualità c'è la
qualità e la qualità percepita dei
quattro elementi del piano marketing
solo uno porta qualità gli altri tre
invece insistono sulla qualità percepita
ed è quindi necessario investire di con
sé conseguenza il quinto e ultimo punto
del paradigma al quale aderì mo dopo
alta qualità velocità 0 magazzino e
controllo e consistenza sugli elementi
del piano marketing avere esterni in
azienda
ad oggi abbiamo formalizzato un comitato
nel quale siedono persone che non
ricoprono ruoli direttivi in azienda non
sono immersi nella contingenza in
azienda non sono del settore e grazie a
questo comitato abbiamo avuto la
possibilità di avere sempre aria fresca
il comitato si esprime insindacabilmente
a maggioranza e chi come me è inserito
nella contingenza dell'azienda è in
minoranza e quindi questo ha permesso a
chi come me era inserito in azienda dove
vivere di contingenza di vedere
opportunità e minacce che non avevamo
visto ed è parlando di prospettive
diverse che vorrei prenderne una qui ora
con voi vorrei fare un esercizio vorrei
provare a testare il livello di
consistenza del sistema nella quale
siamo inseriti nel sistema nel quale
un'impresa che 9 inserito vorrei un po
utilizzare con voi la mia azienda il mio
paradigma come il goniometro per
misurare l'inclinazione a recepire
innovazione da parte del sistema
se noi facciamo questo esperimento è
questo esercizio scopriamo che ci sono
due grosse contraddizioni del sistema
la prima mio padre fonda una manifattura
circa 40 anni fa non aveva nulla e
quindi finanzia l'acquisto di macchinari
con cambiali noi nel 2014 con assunzioni
e fatturato in crescita abbiamo dovuto
fare la stessa cosa
ed ecco quindi la prima contraddizione
il sistema bancario deve sviluppare il
coraggio e desiderio e la
professionalità di riuscire a
intercettare supportare l'innovazione
strumenti come l'attribuzione del rating
basato su la probabilità di fallimento
di un'impresa non possono essere gli
unici strumenti per poter decidere a chi
o meno dare dei finanziamenti
il secondo elemento di contraddizione
che mina l'innovazione un velato
fatalismo pessimistico radicato è una
sorta di freno a mano mezzo tirato una
sorta di fiacchezza frase non finite
iper cautela nei confronti di chi innova
ed è presente tanto nella classe
imprenditoriale quanto nel sistema dove
la classe imprenditoriale inserita e ora
per forza contagiante presente anche sul
mercato l'innovazione nasce dall'azione
contemporanea di due gruppi di persone
il primo sono le persone che desiderano
rinnovare e quelle ci sono il secondo
sono le persone che decidono di non
ostacolare l'innovazione ed è solo
grazie a questo secondo gruppo di
persone che visioni innovazione
imprese e paradigmi nuove imprese e
anche qui sul nostro territorio potranno
avere terreno fertile e moltiplicarsi
quindi se abbiamo la possibilità di
influenzare il processo innovativo
allora abbiamo anche l'obbligo di non
ostacolarlo quando lo vediamo arrivare
grazie